the consequential phone talks at the top
level
we have a good increase in the trade
turnover
despite this specificity of this year
because of the pandemic in january
october it increased by six percent
and it almost reached 1.5 billion
dollars
uh
is facilitated by the work of our
inter-governmental
commission it's co-chairman alexander
novik and the
energy minister of the saudi arabia
and they agreed to have a full scale
plenary meeting called this
intergovernmental
commission this year
foreign
also russian direct investment fund and
the public investment fund of saudi
arabia
cooperate closely together in the
framework called the platform that was
launched by them
that they have already used 2.5 billion
dollars and now we work
on the 12 joint projects in
various fields
is
we cooperate with saudi arabia also in
counteracting the spread of quebec 19.
we work on the issue of organizing in
saudi
arabia the third stage of the clinical
trials of the russian vaccines
but mcv and also we talked about
manufacturing the vaccine in saudi
arabia as well
we also coordinate our actions with
saudi arabia on international markets of
hydrocarbons including uh in the
framework of opec plus
group that also helps us to
bring stability to the situation to the
prices
oil prices in general
absolutely we also discussed
projects in such advanced areas space
exploration and nuclear energy we have
also
agreed to expedite the preparation of
number of documents
that will consolidate our legal base
legal base between our countries
strategic vision group russia islamic
world that was
established a number of years ago
in the context between russia and
islamic cooperation organization and
this strategic vision group
holds annual meeting in the next meeting
by the suggestion of our friends is
going to take place
in saudi arabia and we hope that
circumstances will
allow us to do this in autumn
we also talked in detail about the
situation
in the middle east and north africa it
still
has conflict potential and we have
joined position about the necessity of
taking steps to stabilize the situation
of the council of cooperation of the
arab countries of the gulf that took
place on the 5th of january
in ocular in saudi arabia and
they were talking about the restoration
of the unity of this
important
we deemed that the results of the summit
that took place on that
of january in saudi arabia will
facilitate the creation of opportunity
to promote the initiative on
consolidation
of the on creation establishment of the
collective security
system in the gulf including uh
the initiatives and suggestions from the
russian side as well
we also talked about this urine
settlement
first of all in the context of the
necessity to
fulfill the resolution 2254 we talked
about the efforts taken by russia in
particular
uh within aston format and in geneva
platform
where the negotiations are still ongoing
uh within the framework of the
constitutional committee
foreign for libya we support the efforts
by the u.n
started the intra-libyan inclusive
dialect with the participation of all
the regions and the country with the
participation of both
political forces in the country
and the case wasn't helped by the
long pause with the appointment of the
new special envoy of the
secretary general on libya it seemed
that this matter is going to result
in the nearest future and we hope that
it will allow
our counterparts from the u.n to play
more constructive roles
in all these matters
we welcomed the recent announcement on
the creation
establishment in yemen of the new
government
with the participation of new revisory
council and other political forces and
we welcome the brokering part that saudi
arabia played in this process
[Music]
launching constructive dialogue
regarding the political problems with
the
movement and in this regard
of course we also noticed that there are
some people who really want to
undermine
what i mean is the missile attack
against the riat airport on 30th of
december
at that very moment when a plane landed
with the
members of the new government of the
yemeni republic we insist on the
objective and comprehensive
investigation
of this incident
share the view that the problems of the
region could
not be resolved completely if the
palestinian problem is not
resolved using the current international
legal base including
the arab peace initiative that was
sometime ago proposed by the king of
saudi arabia
foreign we also talked about
other problems other issues in the
region such as iraq and lebanon
we agreed to continue our consultation
regarding all these matters
to exchange opinions exchange our
assessments
it helps us to build a better
understanding of these key issues of the
region
we are quite satisfied with today's
talks i'm grateful to my counterpart and
i give the floor to him
thank you first of all i'd like to thank
mr lavrov
for this hardboarding welcome for the
ability to come to russia to meet
him i have to say that we
are marking 95 years since the
moment your country recognized
diplomatically saudi arabia
and 30 years since the restoration of
diplomatic relations between united
countries
these are important events and i believe
we should
promote the entire range of our
bilateral relations
in the interest of both countries
also we have uh discussed in details the
way to
improve bilateral cooperation in
different areas in investment
in technical cooperation uh all of this
according with in accordance with
the historic uh bilateral
contexts such as the
visit of the saudi king to russia in
2015 then the
the visit by vladimir putin to saudi
arabia in 2017
uh we at
those periods uh several agreements have
been made
and we believe that relations between
our countries need to
develop further
foreign we also
highly value our cooperation within the
opec
plus organization this
was an invaluable contribution to
stabilizing the prices at energy markets
and apart from that it contributed to
protecting the entire economic system
from the dire consequences that could
follow
from the unfavorable
uh such as the coronavirus pandemic and
thanks to our cooperation we were able
to
avoid many of these unfortunate
consequences
also we have discussed a number of
regional topics
including the problem of security in our
sub-region in the gulf region
in the gulf area in this context i have
to
mention the negative role of iran
as it continues to undermine security
and destabilize the region
directly attacking us among other things
and
we believe that this in no way helps
there's no way in the spirit of what we
stand for which
is development and cooperation
and as i made it clear to my russian
counterpart
saudi arabia is
kayla stands for
the development of our country
and of the entire region and all the
countries and peoples
of the region we are also interested
in continuing this cooperation
and we hope that it can be
it can replace the destabilizing factors
promoted
by some of the other countries of the
region
efforts to achieve settlement
in yemen including the area the riyadh
agreements
and the start of the operation of the
new government
martin griffith's work has been
estimated as very valuable we hope that
the ceasefire will open the way to
further diplomatic progress i hope that
there will be an end to all the
destructive
efforts uh by some of the
people such as the houthi
uh militants and we hope that
the will be able to stop the support
coming to these militants from iran
who are providing them with uh ballistic
missiles among other things
a
the constitutional uh committee
continues to
work on the constitution that
is projected to uh finally bring peace
to this war-torn country it is important
to make it impossible
for any outside party to interfere in
syria's domestic
situation because it was always
destructive
in addition we have discussed the
situation in libya saudi arabia's
position on the developments in the
country and of the peace process
is that there's a need for an
inter libyan agreement achieved through
political process that would lay a
foundation
for restoring and rebuilding libya
we support international efforts aimed
at
supporting the ceasefire and the final
goal
is to hold elections in the country
which would lay a foundation
for a stable
we've also discussed a number of other
topics and on the whole
our talks have been very successful
we have agreed on further consultations
and contacts on
all the relay
relevant issues that have to do with
maintaining peace and security in the
region now uh let's go
to the q a session
so first question is to mr lavrov
uh
um
foreign
first question to mr lavrov about the
role of saudi arabia
in resolving the
crisis in the gulf uh
what is russia's role in this process
and what would be what could be russia's
contribution to
achieving stability in the region and
the second question is to
uh mr bin fakhran
[Music]
how would you evaluate your cooperation
in within the opec plus and
and the recent decision by saudi arabia
to reduce the amount of
oil produced
how will it change the relations
between the two countries
as for the unity of the
arab countries of the gulf unity
i think all initiatives they deserve
support and we see the results of the
summit that's very positive but at the
same time i would like to emphasize that
along with kuwait that promoted actively
this initiative saudi arabia played a
special role
as a leading country in the cooperation
council
it uh invited this important summit uh
to exterior territory as you know uh the
summit took place in saudi arabia the
city of
foreign
of course it is an important step toward
the stabilization
in the gulps and russia is not only
interested
in this for many years russia has been
promoting the
well-known concept on the collective
security in the region
and of course at the decision the
result of the summit to will facilitate
and will give more opportunities lead to
more opportunities to discuss such
tools for providing and ensuring
security in the region
foreign
these applications include stabilizing
the prices or energy resources and they
will do
everything to maintain stability
and retain a predictability of the
prices for energy resources
so this is one of the goals of our
cooperation with
russia in terms of energy resources now
the sputnik
news agency's
the question is uh
in regard with regards to the decision
by
the u.s state department
adding the uh the one of the houthi
movements to
the list of terrorist organizations
how do in what way do you believe this
will change relations between
saudi arabia and the united states
foreign
we believe that this decision was
made first of all
not because of specific developments but
uh because of the
entire situation and the
specific attacks by the houthis
against civilian objects against
civilians in yemen
and elsewhere and as well as their other
hostile actions
and all these actions by the houthis
drove the us to make this decision as
for the political process
we support the u.n efforts to organize a
political
peace process but we believe that the
decision
made by the us will not have a negative
effect on the political process
are always undermining the peace
process if
announce clearly that they wish to join
the peace efforts this will be a much
greater contribution to the progress
the peace progress i really want to see
that the political
process doesn't suffer but a lot of
people including in the u.n
they think that it could have a negative
impact unfortunately
foreign
but during the talks today we welcome
the position of saudi
uh rabbit that advocates for
the complete inclusiveness of the
political approaches and
that includes houthi as well
first question is to mr bin
so it will be in arabic
and second question to you mr lavrov you
have already
talked about syria about the syrian
conflict
and uh
what about the fate
of the president of syria
positions became closer regarding the
iranian presence in syria regarding
american presence in syria the first
question from the
al arabiya tv network was forced that
saudi
minister regarding the tension between
the united states regarding the united
states and iran on the other hand
he said that russia supports the
position of iran so
how in saudi arabia they see this
collaboration this cooperation and how
saudi arabia could
assess this situation regarding the
cooperation in the interest of
stabilizing the situation in the region
bashar al-assad
um
so the keys to resolving
the problem of instability in the region
can all be found in tehran it is
important it is necessary that
iran rethink their role in international
affairs
as soon as they understand that it is
important it is necessary
to place the interests of your people
and the development of your economy as a
priority
and not the spread of your ideology in
neighboring state through the use of
different uh terrorist organization and
other destructive efforts
only then we will understand that they
have finally understood what's right
but so far we haven't seen that we
haven't observed
any such change what we see
is their support for the houthis and the
houthis are attacking
ships moving through the red sea
which stabilizes the entire
world economy as as soon as
iran rethinks its philosophy and
rethinks its position international
affairs only then this
the quality change might happen
the only thing i could add that we are
very much interested
in iran and the arab countries
of the gulf uh launched the normalite
the dialect
between them launched normal dialect
started talking about
consolidating the trust and transparency
in the military efforts and
developed that their cooperation and
that's
what our concept of security in the
region is aimed at
uh
most importantly that no one hindered
the process and
took actions to undermine the very
efforts
to create at least
some preconditions for having such a
dialogue
unfortunately our american count reports
uh at least the current administration
has done everything to prevent the
parties from
having such a dialogue
and of course i do agree
with the fact that interference into
their parents of sovereign states
trying to put some ideological ideas or
recipes from the outside is unacceptable
and no one should do this and
unfortunately we can see that in this
region
the us and their closest allies they
behave like an elephant and the china
store
iraq libya and now they attempt to
destroy the
syrian arab republic unfortunately it
has a
long-term echo for all the countries in
the region for all the peoples that
inhabit
[Music]
and we have talked a lot about it today
and we understand the concerns of saudi
arabia
including regarding the situation
around
is concerned
with what is happening around
iranian nuclear program and it is
concerned
with certain actions of iran
in some countries in the region and we
have
uh talked at the conference that we
suggest
holding to discuss the concept of the
collective security
in the cloud it all these matters could
be put on its agenda including all other
concerns of all
other participants including iran
concerns
but most importantly to build such
dialogue around
real equality and that all
external actors they had at the
forefront
the principles of cooperation and didn't
try to
make parties hostile towards each other
and in january we expect a visit of the
foreign affairs minister of the random
ass coach about the rift
and we have already discussed this issue
with him and we will continue this uh
discussion
with uh keeping in mind with the
exchange of opinions that we have had
with
the saudi minister earlier today
as for syria we have a lot in common
in our approaches to the key issues we
of the settlement of the syrian
settlement
a lot of things that we
share regarding the approaches with
saudi arabia
first of all like our saudi friends we
advocate for syrians themselves to
define the ways of developing other
country
and without any interference from the
outsiders
the same is true for the matter of how
do
we assess the presence of the military
forces
of the foreign countries in syria
and another thing
that we have reaffirmed the
common ground about is the importance of
the
prompt resolution of the matter of
bringing back syria to the
arab state league so we share the goal
we share the
same goal but of course we still have to
resolve a lot of matters
on our way towards this goal and these
matters
are quite complicated
and we also cooperate with saudi arabia
in regard of supporting the
negotiations in geneva in the framework
of the constitutional committee and the
work group within this committee
that is supposed to help the fifth uh
meeting
in late january this year
and today we have reaffirmed our
agreement
regarding the context with the
government delegation of the syrian arab
republic and
in the context with the opposing forces
we
try to make these representatives of
the syrian republic to work in a
constructive way
together
we appreciate the position of saudi
arabia that was reaffirmed once again
earlier today and this position is in
uh providing whatever help to the syrian
representatives
including the oppositional
representative that saudi arabia has
swayed upon to find a common ground with
the delegation of the government with
the delegation of independent
representatives of the constitutional
committee
this is a responsible approach and it
goes to show
that we share this understanding that
syrians
should define the future destiny of
their country
themselves
foreign
just one thing i wanted to note saudi
arabia
generally supports the
syrian opposition
in the way they support the syrian
people we do not support any
specific organizational group there
thank you
you